what else you got we got some
relationship advice good advice we can
help Christ
we just got [ __ ] hair plugs and
Brendan what do you do a few minutes
together blew everybody's mind either
eating ass before that about the slavery
thing let's keep going Nathan oarsmen
ores burn from Minnesota Nathan from
Minnesota just so
going into this pretty hard and all of a
sudden she sends me a snapchat message
saying she has something she needs to
tell me
so the message until basically was that
she's still living with her ex and saw
creepin on his Facebook and it says
they're still in a relationship this
little handsome devil god that's Tao dad
sounds like you got sidepiece homey a
good-looking dude too man
well yeah I think he seemed like a nice
guy I'm not gonna say that the guy is
good-looking Brendan okay
here's the thing though if what's her
facebook say like where is she spend a
lot of time with you cuz you homeboy
might if she's that much of a dime piece
he might not just want to let it go so
he's leaving it the relationship status
you know that's true he might be still
caught up he might still want more he
might not ever go on Facebook anymore
either
which could be most people I have no
idea I think my relationship status on
there says I'm like 16 years old so he
hasn't updated it in a while but if
she's sneaking you in and out like it's
only 45 minute type of visits and this
and now the day ya come over you know
like only on commercial breaks and [ __ ]
like see what she has you stored in her
phone as yeah it's Chad from Comcast you
might want ask some questions
[Laughter]
man it's a bummer dude I feel for this
guy but this is also this is what
happens to a lot of women you know and
that's really the sad part is a lot of
this this man could be a lot of women
right now they don't know what's going
on they're talking to some guy you know
he's you know he has girls do it too
though
get my man you know this is what happens
all around this is what happened this is
the fallout of all of it brother he's
driving running as a camper behind him
see they can't protect to his car no
notice that at that camper and he's
driving and who knows this guy could be
damned murderer I'd have to see her to
to see if it the juice is worth the
squeeze I'm saying really I don't need
to see your mansion human no probably as
a big heart and it seems like baby could
be a scumbag though and my boy here
that's true treat him like he's
postmates Oh
making sure make sure you come with a
bag you've come to the house you know
yeah he's post mates yeah bring over
some Fritos bring over something I can
hide the end of the under the bed
remember some kid some little WOM those
tov of fake Andy's that I can wake up in
the middle of night and eat never made
icing where's that post nice guy always
[ __ ] sticking around all the goddamn
time yeah was he installing our cable I
think it's interesting brother but yeah
what does he do what do you guys think
Derek what do you think I mean cool
you're a side piece bro she lives with
him nobody they live together dog nobody
the movie the break-up Vince Vaughn but
here's the thing maybe she was
financially dependent on that dude
they're just broken up she's like trying
to figure [ __ ] out get a job be
independent meets this great handsome
dude no yeah that's beautiful I found
like the nicest thing probably not she
getting double dick well now who knows
if they're having sex he didn't mention
sex Brett spit up mice I guarantee you
no [ __ ] yeah come on thank you all for
this they could just be dating Brandon
come on what do you think cat mmm he
seems like such a nice guy but yeah he
sighed dude we're see where'd he come
from
he is from Minnesota oh nice people to
side dick he does good I heard that yeah
he's that Papa he's that Peyton Manning
Papa John's do
change the call he's that hot girl oh
man look I say look but do you think
he's really into the girl cat or do you
think he's just wondering if he's a
sidepiece or what's going on do you
think he's really into her I think so
I mean he's into her enough to make a
video and send it in and wait for a
response yeah
she's obviously not a listener or
watcher this show well she will be soon
dude yeah she's gonna get to her I hope
she sends a video like all right I got
one for you guys so I'm kind of seeing
this guy inside my boyfriend but he's
really nice and we do share one thing
common we love King in the stands
buzz buzz gangbang yeah my vagina has a
drive-thru
I keep pretending he's a post mate and
installs our cable and then dicks me
down and good luck man yeah what woody
what did he want to know from us oh just
I feel like we help them I think yeah I
think sometimes you just need some
support on what your kind of question it
seemed like you just questioning it man
so I think just play it by ear just
don't get too caught up until you know
it's for real because she's still living
with this man you don't wanna get shot
by this man that's true people be sure
he's doing all he can he has a girl
living with him he has on his facebook
during a relationship if you go to court
you saw those things yeah you know what
you're signing up for bro you sign this
lease and you get shot bruh no you know
people aren't gonna take your side very
easily
yeah people be shooting these days and
if she's bad enough if she's a baddie
getting double dick like this she's a
bali homeboys gonna you know try to keep
it yeah bang bang dude
buzz buzz yeah
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]